[موسيقى]
موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم سنه مقاتلات
اسرائيليات غارات موقعا للمقاومه غرب خان
يونس وارضا زراعيه شرقي رفح جنوبي قطاع
غزه دون وقوع اصابات وقالت كتائب القسام
الجناح العسكري لحماس ان الدفاعاتها
الجويه تتصدت العدوان الاسرائيلي في سماء
القطاع بصواريخ ارض جو وبالمضادات الارضيه
كما قالت حركه حماس عند توزيع العدوان
بقصف قطاع غزه بعد جريمه اعدام الشهيد
عمار مفلح في حواره لن يوقف ثوره شعب
الفلسطيني من جهته قال الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان الغارات تاتي ردا على اطلاق قذيفه من
قطاع غزه امس نحو اسرائيل
قال الامين العام للاتحاد التونسي للشغل
نور الدين الطبوبي ان الاتحاد لم يعد يقبل
بالمسار السياسي الحالي في تونس بسبب
التفرد بالحكم والغموض حسب تعبيره واكد
الطبوبي ان الانتخابات المقبله ستكون بلا
لون او طعم وان الدستور لا يحظى بموافقه
الاغلبيه حسب وصفه
هذا وضعت خمسه احزاب تونسيه معارضه
الناخبين الى مقاطعه الانتخابات التشريعيه
المقرره في السابع عشر من الشهر الجاري
واعتبرت احزاب العمال والجمهور والتيار
الديمقراطي والتكتل والقطب في بيان
المشترك انا الانتخابات تفتقر لابسط
مقاييس النزاهه وشفافيه والديمقراطيه وفقه
تعبيرها
افادت مصادر ومحليه للجزيره بان القوات
التركيه تسادفت نقاط عسكريه تابعه لما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال غربي
سوريا وقالت ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في بيان لها انها وثقت نحو 70
منطقه تعرضت لقصف تركيا من المدفعيه
الثقيله والطيران المسير
قال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
بلاده لن تتراجع اطلاقا عن استكمال انشاء
شريط الامني على عمق 30 كم على طول حدودها
الجنوبيه
ابراهيم قال للجزيره ان كل مواقع
التنظيمات الكرديه في شمال سوريا اهدافه
للقوات التركيه اينما كانت واضاف ان
التنظيمات تستخدم تحالفها مع واشنطن
لاطفاء شرعيه على وجودها في شمال سوريا
وقع وزير الدفاع الروسيه في الجيش ويقوم
على نظيره بلا روسيه فيكتور خارجين على
بروتوكول تعديل اتفاقيه الضمان المشترك
للامن الاقليمي في المجال العسكري بين
البلدين وقال شويكو اين موسكو وميسك
تتخذان اجراءات لتنسيق القدرات القتاليه
لتشكيلات العسكريه الروسيه والبيلاروسيا
قال الرئيس الفرنسي الى بلاده ستواصل دعم
اوكرانيا عسكريه وانها ستزودها بمزيد من
الاسلحه على ان لا يشمل هذا الدعم اي
معدات عسكريه تمكن اوكرانيا من مهاجمه
الاراضي الروسيه بما يقحم فرنسا في الصراع
ودعم قرون الى منح روسيا ضمانات امنيه اذا
عادت الى طاوله التفاوض
ختام الموجز الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]